do you want anything i don't know what i
want i want a lot of things
i want to be with the woman i love on
valentine's day
and i want her to love me back and i
want just one moment of relief
from the gut-wrenching pain and knowing
that that's never gonna happen
we have red bagels
okay yeah that's good enough
joy from friends may not have been able
to find love on valentine's day but
biological anthropologist helen fisher
tells us despite the pandemic remarkably
we're in the midst of a dating
renaissance a report from fisher and the
dating site match
found that singles are now making more
time to look for love
they're refining what they're looking
for in a partner and rethinking how
and where they find love helen fisher is
also chief scientific advisor for match
helen good morning
thanks for being with us how can we
possibly be having a dating renaissance
when it's so hard to
meet people right now well it's even
easier first of all
uh you are absolutely correct uh kovid
is being
killed by cupid cupid is winning and in
fact
um what we found with match i do an
annual study called singles in america
and we did our last study it's science
it's real science
last july in the middle of the pandemic
and as it turns out
singles are spending a lot more time
talking to people
before they go out in person obviously
they're having more meaningful
conversations they're being more honest
and more transparent
uh in those conversations and they're
doing more self-disclosure both men
and women and self-disclosure leads to
intimacy
and last but not least they're caring
less about what they look like and what
a possible
partner would look like and much more
about whether this person is
economically has a full-time job and
is economically stable financially
stable so i'm calling it intentional
dating
and there's no question about it that
people are piling into
uh dating sites actually they're not
even dating sites they're introducing
sites
and certainly with match but all of the
others too they're part they've got time
to do it
and they're earnest about it the bad boy
and the bad girl are over at the same
time
you say the pandemic has kind of slowed
this whole process down
in a good way yes
yeah well it not only i mean i hate to
say that there's anything good about
this pandemic but the bottom line is
what we're really seeing is the
emergence of a new stage in the
dating process you know before the
pandemic you you met um
you know on the internet and then you
went out and met in person
and now there is the real rise of video
chatting
and with that sex is off the table money
is off the table
you've got time to talk to the person
and what we found
at match well it's not at match but in
the study with match
singles in america we found that 50
of people who went on to start video
chatting fell
in love they fell in love with somebody
during coven
you know helen it's tony here i i wonder
and forgive me i'm like the unfrozen
caveman here who's been married forever
and has never online dated but
when you're talking to people on zoom to
date even if you like their personality
aren't you missing that crucial
component of seeing them in the flesh
maybe getting whiff of perfume or
cologne or whatever
isn't that essential to falling in love
and you know
what comes next it's one of the parts of
falling in love but
actually we're being called the new
victorians i mean an awful lot of young
singles and singles
around the around the country actually
don't want to get out into that first
date and deal with the
you know with the sex do i kiss him do i
hold her tent how do i handle this
they don't have to decide whether
they're going to go to a fancy bar or
a very cheap coffee shop it's all off
the table
and they have a lot of time to decide
whether they're going to go out and meet
somebody in person i mean now with the
video chatting
it's a vetting process and over 50 of
of singles met somebody on the internet
and decided they didn't want to go and
meet them in person and
as much as 64 percent did but you know
we were talking
they call it love at first sight they
don't call it first smell or love at
first
text they call it love at first sight
and you can see somebody on the internet
i mean you can see
where they live you can see the way they
smile and move and
uh you know a great deal about them and
you know the brain
this brain i put people in brain
scanners and study the brain circuitry
of romantic glove
it's like a sleeping cat it can be
triggered instantly uh
just when somebody says something funny
or somebody says something sweet or kind
and it can easily be done on the
internet and that's exactly what's
happening
helen it's always a thorough pleasure
talking to you we appreciate it uh
like a sleeping cat i like that i like
that a lot